un artista abstracto quiere crear dos
pinturas triangulares proporcionales las
dimensiones de una de las pinturas se
muestran en la figura son estas de aquí
que tan largos deben de ser los lados de
la segunda pintura ok si queremos que
las dos figuras sean proporcionales lo
que estamos pidiendo es que los dos
triángulos sean semejantes y de hecho
aquí en la figura están marcados los
ángulos correspondientes este ángulo de
aquí que voy a pintar en color naranja
se corresponde con este de acá si los
dos tienen una marquita de manera
similar este ángulo en rosa tiene dos
marcas y corresponde a este de acá y
finalmente el ángulo correspondiente a
este de tres marcas de aquí arriba es
este de aquí abajo que también tiene
tres marcas y que voy a pintar con azul
vale bueno que otra cosa sabemos acerca
de los triángulos que son semejantes
bueno los triángulos que son semejantes
también tienen la razón de los lados
correspondientes igual vale la razón de
los tres lados correspondientes es la
misma entonces vamos a utilizar eso para
determinar los lados que nos faltan
en el segundo triángulo pero primero
vamos a marcar los lados del color que
le corresponde a este lado que es
opuesto al ángulo naranja lo voy a
pintar de color naranja vale entonces
este lado corresponde a este ángulo pero
entonces este lado corresponde a este
lado de acá porque acá también
este es el opuesto al ángulo naranja de
manera similar este a este lado de acá
el lado bc es el lado opuesto al ángulo
rosa aquí abajo tendría que ser el lado
de zeta y finalmente tenemos el lado
hace opuesto al ángulo en color azul que
es correspondiente a este de acá vale al
x zeta que es el ángulo en que es el que
está pintado de azul también podemos
pensar a este lado naranja como el lado
entre el ángulo azul y el ángulo rosa y
vemos que aquí abajo pasa lo mismo
verdad el lado naranja es el que está
entre el ángulo azul y el ángulo rosa
bueno pero ahora si vamos a las
proporciones entonces como estos dos de
aquí son triángulos semejantes ya que
sus ángulos correspondientes son iguales
proporciones de lados correspondientes
deben de ser iguales es decir debemos
tener que ave
voy a poner por acá a b / x x si es
igual a y ahora vámonos a los rosas que
son los lados correspondientes ahora en
color rosa esto de aquí es igual abc
entre z y también esto va a ser igual a
vámonos al azul igual a sea sea entre zx
zx todas las razones entre lados
correspondientes son iguales vale bueno
pero de aquí sabemos algunos numeritos
verdad déjame poner con color naranja
este este ave este ave sabemos que es un
5 este x y sabemos que es un 2
luego el bc -el veces sabemos que es un
elche z no lo sabemos lo queremos
determinar ahorita lo despejamos vámonos
a los azules el cea mide 10 y el zx
también queremos determinarlo y bueno
entonces aquí tenemos una triple
igualdad de la cual vamos a poder sacar
dos ecuaciones y de ahí despejar los
lados que nos interesan vale bueno
entonces voy a empezar con esta primera
igualdad
5 medios igual a 9 / etcétera entonces 5
medios es igual a 99 entre receta y ez
estoy aquí es una ecuación lineal en una
incógnita así que se puede hacer de
muchas formas déjame hacerlo de la
siguiente manera voy a multiplicar por
receta de ambos lados para acá y para
acá vale con esto cancelamos ez a la
derecha y nos queda que z por cinco
medios es igual a nueve ahora lo que voy
a hacer es multiplicar por dos quintos
de ambos lados lo voy a hacer con color
amarillo es el recíproco de cinco medios
multiplicó aquí por dos quintos por este
lado de este lado también por dos
quintos y con esto logramos cancelar
este 2 con este 2 este 5 con este 5 y
obtenemos que ese zeta ceta es igual a 9
por 12 18 y 18 entre 5 es 18 quintos
diez y ocho quintos y esto de aquí es
igual a 3.6 vale entonces ya tenemos la
medida del lado de zeta
3.6 déjame ponerlo aquí 3.6 muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer este la igualdad del
primer término de la primera proporción
con la última para obtener cuánto vale
zx vale bueno entonces voy a copiar con
color naranja el cinco medios cinco
medios es igual a 10 entre zx 10 10 voy
a poner un poco más bonito entre zx
bueno vamos a resolverlo ahora de otra
forma para que no sea tan aburrido vale
ahora lo que voy a hacer es voltear
ambos lados de la igualdad es decir
tomar los recíprocos que obtenemos
tenemos que dos quintos dos quintos es
igual a z x entre 10 7x entre 10 y ahora
podemos multiplicar por 10 de ambos
lados de esta igualdad para que aquí se
cancele 10 y quede despejado zx vale
entonces nos queda que zx es 10 por 2 o
sea 20 entre 5 entonces todo esto es
igual a 4 y por lo tanto zx es igual a
4 lo voy a poner por acá zx es igual a 4
y con esto terminamos para que el
artista pueda hacer sus pinturas
proporcionales entonces las el segundo
triángulo debe tener medidas 2 3 puntos
6 y 4